joining me here we're back here on the
program on a big news day is my
colleague from the nfl media group ian
rappaport how are you doing ian
uh i'm doing it's been a couple weeks
you know this is this has been insane so
where did this all come from with tyree
kill i woke up this morning i see your
tweet i'm like get the hell out of here
i'd look for the blue check mark to see
it wasn't one of those fake accounts
that that use your name and likeness and
stuff so i first
i first heard about this on saturday
actually
that something was not and i didn't know
what it was but it was something is not
right between the chiefs and tyree kill
and as far as i was concerned you know
things were going along swimmingly they
were doing a contract extension they
were working things out he was going to
get paid in the low 20s and then as
devante adams contract numbers came out
and tyree killed did not like those very
much because he wanted to be
he want basically wanted the chief's
offer to be bigger than it was so when
devonta adams contract came out he was
like why i should be the highest paid my
numbers need to be a lot higher and they
were like
well actually his numbers are you know
three years 66 over the first three
that's the most relevant
but that break really led to some some
frayed
feelings i get some tension and so you
know they went back and forth they
realized it wasn't well aging through
rosenhaus got permission to seek a trade
and i think once um it was clear what
the chiefs could get in return then we
were off to the race
so what the chiefs got in return uh from
miami was the best offer or
did anyone else come in and blow him
away but tyree going to go to miami what
was that best you can tell first of all
yes tyrique wanted to go to miami that
was his preferred destination and that
was really the place
you know that was in the driver's seat i
think the jets did a good job of
offering a competitive package not their
first rounder but two second rounders
and more basically if you line up the
draft charts it was similar
um so yes the jets
um
you know the jets were in it i just
never felt like they were really really
in it because i kept hearing all along
kyrie kill wants to go to the gotham so
when everyone said the judge i'm like
yes i get it but he wants to go to the
dolphins and generally the player can
have a strong saying where he goes
because he's going to be the one
agreeing to the contract
so why didn't the chiefs pay tariq what
what he wanted
to keep him what do you think well
you know the chiefs have some cap issues
and unlike some other teams they have
not done a lot of conversions they have
not done a lot of
restructures they haven't done a lot of
pushing money to the future they have
been fiscally far different from a lot
of teams
um you know i think it's just
philosophically from the owner they have
just not yet done a lot of restructures
so
i think they set a price tariq is
awesome he's worth x and when he wasn't
getting x from the chiefs they were like
all right well let's just figure it out
somewhere else
and i honestly think it's a it's a place
where everyone can be okay with it
because it's such a huge offer for the
chiefs
they can take a player they drafted and
developed and paid
and reload a little bit
what do you think about the packers i
mean they obviously have multiple picks
thanks to trading
devonte adams to where adams wanted to
go um
where were the packers in all this
um they
they inquired from my understanding they
at least took a look at it i don't get
the sense it got very serious but i do
believe that they at least made a phone
call and got engaged somewhat but you
know my sense is the packers are kind of
more like the chiefs and they're like we
got the money we're going to build some
depth we're going to
go in the draft
and we're going to see what happens um
you know so i really feel like
um i feel like they're going to draft
and develop all right in the two minutes
i have left with you what's baker
mayfield's options and uh and trade
market value right now
um i mean he's got some options i think
it's more it more has to do with whether
or not the chiefs will eat some money
um and i i feel like it's more
you know how much money the i'm trying
to achieve the bronze uh
the browns you know how much money will
the cleveland browns eat of baker
mayfield's contract
and
you know what will the drastic
competition be it's not going to be like
they can make it anticipate it's not
going to bite the participate there's
not that many spots
but i do believe eventually he will be
trained no sure but i mean like
there aren't many places that are
willing to bring somebody in and
and give a starting role to let alone
compete is seattle one of these places i
mean like what what like where are the
team options that you say there there
are options where are they to me it's
it's seattle and the panthers seattle
panthers seem more likely but certainly
contract wise they're gonna have to
figure it out eat some money come up
with a compensation package that's worth
it
carolina seems like a good spot and
maybe around the time of the draft kind
of like last year with bridgewater they
do a deal just this time that would be
the pastor's inquiry and the first thing
got to kind of jump off for uh so i i
gotta jump too take care and you'll be
well all right later
then the first and third overall picks
of the 2018 draft will compete for the
job
uh honestly i i like i told you they
should go sign josh rosen and complete
the triumvirt of all the first round
quarterbacks that are then just let him
compete
in one of the oddest uh
american idol football american idol
competitions ever trade for saquon let's
just run
a 2018 draft
oh my goodness
what a wild
day
in the nfl
and i've said that now for i think 14
days straight
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here